travis scott were basically trying to
cancel i'm saying like this people are
dying out here travis scott is doing the
robot this [ __ ] is like
that's the video that's making this
round
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever it's a
pretty good robot though yeah somebody's
dying this motherfucker's like
what the [ __ ] is going on it's a good
robot so there was an account of a of a
young lady who was talking about what
happened at the concert right so she was
trying to describe how [ __ ] nuts it
was when people were bum rushing towards
the stage okay so it was so tight
in five four three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain
podcast we have a very very special
guest here
manscape your balls will thank you hell
yeah what's up shout out promo code we
out here boom boom boom boom the kind
fanny pack
nick does shave his butt too so actually
i'd be shaving my [ __ ] yo you shave
your butt huh whole my butt whole now my
bad that's his cheeks like the whole
there's no hair on my cheeks he's gonna
show you his ass consistently all the
[ __ ] time uh sometimes yeah two
months in a while i've seen your ass
more than i've seen mariel's ass
you're welcome
you're welcome disgusting
gilbert dude show your ass way too much
every show is asked too much though also
it's shaped manscaped
you use manscape i do
i do only because they gave it to me for
free but yeah it's good [ __ ] yeah what
is it
what do you mean
like are the razors are they they they
got it's everything was a manscape that
bro i'm trying to help you out [ __ ] i
think they stopped sponsoring my podcast
so we're not talking about them
they have great underwear they have a
great shaver it gets up in the up in
there you know what i mean yeah yeah oh
i like it it's got a little hook
i got a little light i use a straight
razor for my [ __ ] bro
what do you guys call the area between
the the ball sack and the butthole
goose what is it though
is it bulbal spongiosis is the medical
troposaurus spongiosis
bobo spongiosis
oh it's a muscle i was uh i was in an
anatomy class
they have an enemy they have the picture
of like everything and then the middle
is the bulbous spongiosis
and that made me laugh and i was like
hey guys that was one-on-one time with
the professor after class he was like
come here nick let me show you my
bulbasaurosis and i was like yeah i
could feel it for sure wow the global
spongiosis it's a muscle look hell yeah
in the diaphragms i can't see [ __ ]
it's not the taint it's like a beside
you machine that's disgusting
or taint i think they're in do you have
to we have to choose one you know what
you have to choose
when i was in high school
i remember two dudes that got into a
[ __ ] fist fight over this in class
over this like intelligence
so this dude i don't know how this
[ __ ]
i don't know how this came up but i just
remembered rum deep dude
talking about those these two dudes i
don't know how the conversation came up
but he was talking about oh what's that
area between your balls he's like yeah
that's the gooch he goes ah bro that's
the taint he goes
ah scooch he goes no it's tame stop
being stupid
and i think from the moment he called
him stupid yeah it was on he was like
the [ __ ] you just said and they started
throwing down over arguing about whether
it's a gooch or taint and everybody was
crying [ __ ] laughing while these two
dudes are just whaling on each other
what's it called [ __ ]
that's how ghetto my school was tight
though that is tight because that at
least they're strong in their
convictions and that's what matters
passionate people you know people don't
take a stand anymore you know that's
true people they just uh you know yeah
go with the wind yeah i would say
we are here to talk about the greatest
fight card in the history of the ufc
probably one of the best yeah it was
pretty good pretty funny the best but
yeah i mean even the undercard was fake
undercard was actually arguably
there's some fights on the undercard
that were better than actually no i
don't think so no the card was dope
though dude you see that guy chris
barnett yeah he's the guy who knocked on
uh knocked out uh gian velante
heavyweight yeah and then he didn't
flip into
like the sport you've seen him fight in
asia like in japan i've never heard that
he's amazing so he had a pretty decent
name out in like japan because you know
he's a large heavyweight
very [ __ ] flexible dude he actually
did an exhibition against joelle ramelan
or romero in grappling he's a taekwondo
guy too yeah
both his parents are black belts that's
crazy like he was on arrow helwani and
he was he was telling his whole story
very likable guy that dude's gonna be a
star bro it's he uh
yeah he's just known for like his
flexibility he's just very awkward yeah
i mean but super [ __ ] fun to watch so
he was fighting in asia this whole time
and i think he fought in the lfa or some
type of american institution after that
and then he got assigned to the ufc his
debut fight he didn't do very well
uh did not do well at all but
he came out with a knockout look at him
now yeah and he'll kick to the dome bro
that's heavyweight it was like a
capoeira one too because he touched the
ground with his head and he lifted his
leg up and knocked this [ __ ] out
and then he front flipped on his butt
like this yeah i was like
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah ryan has bubble spongiouses
and then we've got that
[Music]
oh yeah alex pereira dude wow that
[ __ ] was sick that's that dude
is scary looking fat flying did he
kickboxing he beat him he beat him in
the decision in china i think actually
knocked him out in china he knocked him
out he knocked him out once and then
beat him to a decision wow
but that was quite some time ago but
also the the fight before he got knocked
out izzy was beating his ass oh really
izzy was beating his ass yeah okay okay
so and he just got caught but also alex
pereira has fought like his his
kickboxing record very good the only
guys he's ever lost to are like the top
of the top of the dutch style kickboxing
so it's going to be interesting to see
how well he kind of grows in the ufc
because
his wrestling held up pretty well in the
in this yeah in the first round or so it
was a lot of wrestling yeah and then he
hit that beautiful pitch perfect like uh
flying knee look
and he's he slapped him bro that dude
was [ __ ] knocked out yeah so we'll
see what happens he's only four and one
he doesn't have that many fights in mma
so it's interesting though because i
don't know who the guy was that he was
fighting right i was looking up his
accolades he's a bjj black belt but i
think the the difference that i'm seeing
now is like
i think only recently we've been seeing
an emphasis in the grappling wrestling
part yeah of jiu-jitsu that's the
difference maker yeah and that's what he
couldn't do yeah he couldn't get to it
to the point where he could take him to
the floor and that's always been the
knock on jiu jitsu guys like they just
don't have the wrestling ability to take
it to the ground like you look at
mackenzie dern right very good grappler
but sometimes like she fought uh marina
rodriguez couldn't take her down great
jutsu great attacks but getting them
like habib style or like islam style
being able to take to the ground
whenever they want and then be able to
control them to get the submissions very
different the hard part about her was
that i think for the the couple of
fights that she won before that
when she was
when she was taking control on the
ground is because she slipped and made a
mistake and they fell into that trap
exactly this one it wasn't happening she
had to go to her and try to take her
down and she couldn't do it and that's
the difference between a high level mma
fighters and high-level grapplers than
the guys that can't make that transition
happen so it's going to be interesting
to see like
like you look at [ __ ] chimaya do we
even talk about that
oh my god so if you guys don't know who
another scary guy tamayo is he is the
reincarnation of the devil this fool is
pure evil and he's crazy
i killed everybody and everybody was
like even everybody in abu dhabi was
like yo bro
yeah he was saying some some crazy [ __ ]
you look at a guy like that
there's a reason why nobody wants to
fight this guy he's only been punched
twice
he has four fights he's crazy wins then
he does actual strikes to his face
that's crazy two significant strikes and
they count punches off the bottom too
yeah
that's how [ __ ] good he is
damn that's wild dude the guy can man
like picked him up man handled the [ __ ]
out of him took him to the corner to
dana white because he saw him on his
phone and was like watch my fight he was
like yo what are you doing brother
watch my fire damn dude that dude's
gonna be a problem have you seen clips
of him wrestling
he's so fast he's so good he shoots
super fast i don't know how you're gonna
stop that [ __ ] i think this is one of
the rare cases where you see a guy like
this where you're like
he could beat usman yeah there's a good
shot he could be usement because he's
not scared that i think that's half the
battle right yeah like you fight a guy
that's as dominating as usman is as good
as he is
and you are a contender in the sport and
you're like a young gun
and you fight a guy like that i feel
like this dude if hamzad can run through
kobe then that's going to be a bad sign
for gooseman oh yeah for sure yeah if he
can if he runs through colby he's not a
true 170 guy he's 185 for sure we don't
even know if he can make weight again
yeah
you see him with a towel yeah he didn't
tailgate for
sure he's getting to that point where
170 is not easy for him anymore he's
huge he's he's even big for 185 so it's
like what the [ __ ] he could go to light
heavyweight if he wanted to
so 170 is not his weight class but dude
he's a beast he's got a man house and
[ __ ] he looked way bigger than
uh the chinese duty fought yeah
huge baffle you want to talk about a
[ __ ] looking guy
that dude looked asian as [ __ ] like he
looked like a like the word [ __ ]
yeah
and he has hands too he has bombs in his
hands he's scary dude they call him the
leech what the name is that the leech
that's a bad name
you dry boy
don't give me your penis i'm going to
suck you dry that'll call me leech for
no reason yeah he was looking for that
bomb he just ducked under shot
beautiful it was so it was like it was
choreographed like fighting
it was amazing that was crazy
who's he fighting next he's gonna fight
like a top 10 guy he has to i think he
might fight gilbert burns next or luke
if i see gilbert burns it might be dope
that might be a good fight if he's
imagine he just destroys gilbert that
would be scary that'd be like holy then
you're like what do you do what do you
do with this guy yeah that'd be scary
he's so exciting to watch fight because
of how complete he is like
we we haven't seen a fight long enough
to see the hole in this game so i'm just
curious to see what it is you know what
he says too he's like i want war brother
i want war i want i don't want easy
fight i come in i smash guys i want
fight to last longer like that's what he
says
he literally just wants to he's like i
want war like rory mcdonald and robbie
lawler this is what i want he wants to
be bloodied up he wants he wants to be
crazy this guy should be nuts
bar for real
i already know what that means what do
you know what do you think he's god
willing or something like that god
willing for praise to god yeah what a
bad rap allahu akbar god i know it's
actually very beautiful
we're over here judging this
[ __ ]
the fact that he's like i will kill
everybody not fight yeah not strike i
will kill everybody i will kill he looks
like a bond villain yo yeah so on the
main card if you guys don't know there's
two [ __ ] bangers of fighters it was
gaechi
and michael chandler michael chandler
came from an institution uh bellator he
was there he was like a multiple champ
over there everybody has the wine scene
fight in the ufc and he gets uh teamed
up against justin gaichi the god of war
the for real the god of [ __ ] war that
fight was nuts oh he's this was probably
i just never seen so many people they
just swung yeah i was kind of mad
why i want look it was a great fight
whatever but in my head
i hold justin gaichy as far his
credentials in the ufc hold him up here
yo yeah and i hold michael chandler like
somewhere around here and i feel like
just engaged he could have pitched a
shutout
but i feel like he actively was like nah
i want to put on a show i think i think
chandler
like because i used to think that too
but i think chandler's just better than
what if you love so much why don't you
marry me
yeah it's true dude no change so much
why don't you marry him already
defending your boyfriend dude chandler
round one the in and out movement was
[ __ ] amazing he rocked the [ __ ] out
of justin gaichi in the beginning gate
you was keeping it now he was fine
like chandler gates you could easily be
champs for sure i just never want justin
gates to be on a mic
that full sounds like he has cte so bad
dude yeah i
just want to come here for war there's
more
you see his [ __ ] eyes just kind of
goes off in the distance like he's one
of those people it's a good thing he's
fighting professionally because i think
he would just be out in the streets just
banking on him he was going to be a
social worker do you know that yeah
that's crazy to be a social worker he
seems like a very nice guy though kill
[ __ ] study please yeah this guy
his vocabulary he's very minimal
i would never say this to his face i
feel like he got more of a cleft lip
than uh comes out chemical
he has the little breathing issue too
right because he got sucked in the face
so much like he has to get surgery for
it oh really
he hasn't fixed it yet he's just gonna
do it after he retires
yeah i guess because it's probably gonna
break again yeah what's the [ __ ]
that's true that dude that's true it was
such a [ __ ] bloodbath that was
amazing
the upper cut he caught him with the
fact that chandler didn't go out and
then got up and kept swinging and like
getting down
the moment even when chandler put his
hands down and was just getting cracked
in the [ __ ] face
i was like what the [ __ ] that if i was
insane like what is he doing what is he
doing yeah but he's still there
it was not no that [ __ ] was insane i
thought he was gonna be it when he
because he was looking for that slip
uppercut all night yup he was he that
was the shot he was trying to land and
the fact that he landed it and put him
on his back and i thought that the fight
was going to be over and when he
sprawled on him and he started punching
his belly i was like come on bro yeah i
was like stand up but he did have his
arms dude
that long was holding on for dear life
his grip is always good like there's
multiple times if you see a michael
chandler fight where he's been put into
a rear naked and all he needs to get is
one wrist and he always twists out yeah
hold puts on the other side and twist
out which most people can't do that [ __ ]
i've seen multiple people try that in
mma but for some reason michael chandler
when anybody tries to get his neck from
the back he always does that [ __ ] his
wrestling grenade like i think it's just
his scrambles he scrambles his grip is
so strong dude when he picked up justin
gaiji and he dumped him and he went out
the back
hooked the leg and came out on top i was
like that's beautiful this is what
like i feel like we get more wrestling
scrambles like that i feel like that'll
it'll make wrestling way more popular
like even in the usman uh covington
fight they had some really dope
scrambles too and even though usman was
just bullying the fool like
okay so in the fight do you do you
consider that that uh kobe take down a
takedown
well uh
when he dropped into his knee for a
second or whatever or i guess because i
remember under he
shot
and then usman was running to the cage
and he was on the side of the cage
because i remember hearing dc talk about
it being like that was a takedown so i
was like all right that might be a
takedown that dude knows more than i do
so yeah
and even i think uzman said in the
post-fight press conference that like he
was like yeah that's a takedown yeah but
i don't i wonder if it officially cheers
yeah but who gives a [ __ ] like because i
heard colby's talk about it in the in
the post conference and i was like but
is like if that was something he was
chasing in that fight that's [ __ ]
stupid dude yeah like who gives a [ __ ]
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends a long time
sponsor of this podcast because i
[ __ ] with them heavy my friends
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore and real
projects to create and the support of
fellow
creatives now if you're like me out
there and you want to learn something
you don't want to go ahead and search
all of youtube to find some of the worst
instructors that don't know what the
hell they're talking about skillshare
can help you out i've been using
skillshare and i freaking love it
currently right now i am taking the
ultimate self-care playbook by jonathan
van ness you guys might like it too
listen skillshare isn't just about like
finding uh how to do youtube videos it's
just they have a bunch of everything for
you guys to pick and choose from and
right now i'm on my self-care playbook
playbook journey and that's what i'm
doing right now doing a lot of stuff
based on mindfulness and skillshare has
the tools and the classes to help me out
my friends so check it out explore your
creativity at skillshare.com brain and
get a one month free trial of premium
membership that's one month of a premium
membership at
skillshare.com
brain
colby why were you not fighting hard in
the first three rounds that's that's the
thing that should have been he looked
off i think it was a i think a lot of it
was probably just the moment or just
being able to kind of get things going
because they're so similar in skill
level they're very similar yeah like i
find it hard for when people say like
usement is just that much better it's
pretty [ __ ] close though oh yeah
especially the last two rounds yeah when
kobe and also two credits of kobe
the fact that he got dropped like twice
with that left hook i thought that was
it too yeah i was like oh this is it
there's no way he's gonna out of that
and the fact that he got knocked down
came back and fought even better
in the last couple of rounds just shows
like oh man this guy that fourth round
was all his he was beating the [ __ ] out
of oozman yeah yeah and his weapon was
kind of like he was kind of getting
sloppy and i was getting like hell dude
what's going on what's happening here
yeah what happened to you know the uh
what you call like the the precision
that he's really good at but then again
it's just like he probably wasn't
expecting him to rally like that right
right it was he was probably like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
dude
at the end of the round he hit him with
this hard round house right to useman's
gut and he felt that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
dude that was great i think he landed a
solid kick too that he felt really well
like it was just cold and then austin
usman was like oh [ __ ] that kind of hurt
yeah but you haven't seen ever yeah
because we've seen usman get cracked at
the head with hooks and he eats him and
comes right back yeah but the body
shot's a little different he's a big boy
he's huge man he made kobe kolpkovy he
made colby look pretty small too even in
the first fight i was like there's a
size difference here i'm surprised he
could even get to 170 dude he's somebody
i'm always shocked at because he's older
now too and he's
making 170 every [ __ ] time do you
think that's cool
there's a whole like argument about this
i mean if he's if he is i'm not
surprised if he's not that's great yeah
but not for real
that's it do you think he is he might be
who knows man that's whack maybe like
some human growth hormone or something i
think well i think a lot more people in
the ufc are
are on something yeah they shouldn't
even think because like you think the
usada is all good but also like uh
there's a lot of people that say
the testing is not as good as what we
really think and they're not testing for
certain like uh what's we're looking for
like off-market
uh growth hormones or whatever the case
may be so like there's so many different
variations apparently you could hire
somebody to just a chemist in like india
or some [ __ ] like yo build me this
[ __ ]
can you make me some steroids
whatever you want
a designer steroid that's all i'm
looking for yeah like all that [ __ ]
that's like a whole nother market that's
like even crazier than we even really
think so who knows man any all these
guys could be pot for the [ __ ] i don't
know man if he's not on steroids i'm
still kind of shocked because he just
looks massive for real either way i'm
cool with it yeah i'm okay
i'm happy with it do you think he's
better than gsp
i'm starting to think so yeah yeah it's
starting to like yeah he's trying to
take over what if they both fought
each of them at their prime how do you
think who do you think will win i think
usman wins
i kind of think
gsp ooh
because he's the better i think the
striking variety is a little more
diverse and i feel like
i don't want to say usman doesn't seem
as comfortable to me in the cage
but i feel like gsp has a little
different aura but who knows i don't
know he's surprised i feel he has a more
diverse skill set they have the same
body type too long as arms short torso
short legs and they're both [ __ ]
strong as [ __ ] like yeah like they're
both genetic freaks yeah so who [ __ ]
knows dude but i think he's so sick i
think right now as the evolution is gone
i think usman probably has the
better on paper resume than gsp just
because the evolution of the sport
generations dudes wants beat everybody
liking he's lapping him dude i'm
surprised he doesn't want to just retire
now because yeah more arguably more than
habib he could retire yeah oh yeah habib
just did his one lap he's done so many
laps now it's like
what else do you need here who else are
you gonna be you know what's crazy to
see
uh justin gaichi and michael chandler
fight again in the lightweight division
it is interesting to see like man habib
is just that good
yeah like he walked down justin gaichi
and was like he had him moving backwards
yeah and he was eating his best shots
and
didn't really seem like he was phased at
all yeah he didn't even get rock like he
stumbled a little bit but i don't think
it was it was i think it would just him
just kept marching forward crazy thing
is like justin gates he when he was on
joe rogan's not justin gaichi uh michael
chandler was on joe rogan's podcast he
was talking about he has the tools to
beat habib
you do not you absolutely do not yeah if
you're going to war with justin gates
like that and you're losing you're not
going to beat habib no even
i feel like the only style that would
beat khabib though is a good wrestler
with heavy hands i mean that's why when
geichi fought khabib i was like i was
kind of like if anyone's going to beat
him it's a guy like gaichi you know what
i mean but the thing about habib that
everyone gets is like he's not him and
islam are not just wrestlers right yep
it's their overall grappling iq and
skill set like that brings a whole
nother issue like
if you
for instance with the usment thing right
colby shot in took us back if that was
habib
you're going up dude and i feel like
you're getting your back taken and you
have way more threats to worry about
rather than just getting them off the
cage yeah yeah so it's a whole nother
[ __ ] thing so
i don't know man i don't think michael
chandler
has the skill set to be able to keep
keep up without b but it still
holds true that him retiring was
probably a good thing because yeah yeah
no one's really showing up that's like
oh i don't know if this guy could beat
habib but we'll see what happens because
we got december we have [ __ ] dustin
poirier and charles oliveira that's
gonna be nice fight that fight card is
even more stacked dude i didn't know
frankie edgar was in his forties
yeah stop fighting bro yeah he's gotta
stop dude dude did you see that slow-mo
pick of him getting kicked in the face
with his face melted they're posting
that [ __ ] everywhere did you see that
[ __ ] i didn't see the picture now dude
bring that [ __ ] photo up it literally
looks like his face was melting that's
sad bro i love frankie edgar he was
winning he was it's just it looked like
somebody he was fighting his daddy
because he's so small compared to 135
dude he's just too and he he just always
never had that power yeah like that was
always his knock is that he would hit
you a gang but
oh my god i haven't seen that that is
the kick that knocked him out and his
whole looks like donald duck right there
damn dude a little platypus he's got a
donald duck face that's like a
chimpanzee face right here yeah i feel
like frankie edgar was one of the first
people that i saw that was that would
have just stayed there and plant his
feet he was always moving he was like
the he was that that bridge between the
new style of fighting and old style
fighting yeah and at the time when he
came in he's like it's all about
movement cutting angles and all those
other [ __ ] even before dominick cruz so
like i just remember him doing that but
he's still doing it now and relatively
well yeah but he's also in his 40s it's
different
not just that it's also the that
he just doesn't have the the like he
doesn't hurt anybody yeah what i mean
he's winning for sure yeah he's running
on points but it's like if for if you're
in there for a long time and the guy
other guy has some power and you get
caught you get caught that's what
happened frankie goes down to 125 he
might be able to do something yeah maybe
i don't even know if his he can even
handle the weight cut right now he's in
his 40s yeah it's i think that's 40.
he's got nothing to prove you know it's
like he did it and the more fight and it
sucks because unfortunately this is the
way the sport is but the more fights you
lose even your anderson silva the goat
right even if you're anderson the more
fights you lose towards the end of the
career you're kind of less thought of as
the goat from when you tarnish your yeah
like it tarnishes your legacy yeah it
does can i feel like the same thing's
happening with frankie frankie edgar
beat the living [ __ ] out of yahya
rodriguez do you remember that he oh
that's right beat that full-time
swanson yeah yeah he beat up a lot of
good [ __ ] guys two an oblivion too
like i remember y'all rodriguez's face
was [ __ ] up dude and he's and uh
[ __ ] max hallway smashed frankie
edgar yep right and then he's going to
fight with your rodriguez what do you
think that how that's well i think yeah
rodriguez is going to die
i don't i almost said i hope so but i
thought you mean i thought you were
going to say he's going to lose but i
hope so but this [ __ ] is weird
like all his fights end up in some weird
controversy there's some weird [ __ ] that
happens with him i know like mma math is
weird right like just because somebody
beats somebody else that you formally
beat doesn't necessarily mean you win
that fight either but the way that just
max holloway has done against everybody
yeah i just don't see yeah also because
yay hasn't fought in so long two years
yeah he has such so much ring rust and
max holloway is always game so it's like
i don't know if that's going to that's a
tough first fight back for you yeah yeah
but in my head like i hope this isn't a
thing but i love max is like my favorite
he's like my favorite fighter yeah so
anytime my favorite fighter is fighting
i always feel like oh like i feel weird
right and i just get anxious when
because yeah you're so [ __ ] like
remember the elbow wrong chan sung junk
so random he was getting his ass beat
and part of me still to this day doesn't
really believe it was on purpose oh for
sure it wasn't
like i don't want to be the guy that poo
poos it but part of me feels like i i'm
skeptical still what do you think
i don't know i mean
yeah i i could see it being an accident
like what the [ __ ]
just [ __ ] marry him already dawg
your two boyfriends michael chandler
i could see him in an accident for sure
well that beat needs to come into the
mix too and see what he could do that's
my [ __ ] whatever abe lincoln what
happened to him dude his diaphragm all
[ __ ] up oh for real he can't breathe
and [ __ ] that's why he can't breathe
yeah it's like it's like a long term he
i think he retired bro he was on the
five dollar bill he retired a little bit
and then came back or whatever well
maybe
he signed the [ __ ] emancipation
proclamation
put a top hat on that dude i gave him
a top hat in the ring at all times
that's because that beats my height but
he fights at like 125. is he really that
tall he's like six feet tall he's like
five eleven maybe five eleven six feet
at 145 that's a [ __ ] that's what
i'm saying dude he's cutting first of
all you could see his heart beat through
his chest it's like i know we're all
about this [ __ ] weight advantage
height advantage thing but yeah it's a
little much yeah these are organs and
[ __ ]
10 pounds and you'll probably do a lot
better and i bet you he'll be able to
last a lot longer too yeah especially at
155 wow he's he's skillful bro he's good
he's a beast he's good everywhere he's
he's like another hamzah dude yeah but
which is crazier striking yeah that's
true the little sweepsy be pulling on
everybody he that fools dude shane
burgos dude did you see all these little
muay thai [ __ ] leg sweeps he was
doing yeah those were kind of crazy [ __ ]
was that that [ __ ] was exciting dude
i've never seen anybody do that in mma
yeah the inside leg sweep like they look
like kicks almost but he was just
sweeping he's like he was trapping the
head and sweeping
it to nate
like that type of [ __ ] yeah it was so
[ __ ] nice dude
the other guy never i couldn't like the
other pace the other [ __ ] was
putting on was so insane though yeah
what was his name
he literally never stopped coming
forward yeah the whole [ __ ] time that
guy's a savage man he is his leg was
destroyed it's terrible it was just a
matter of like when i was watching it
i was just like um he's gonna get his
number because burgos doesn't get
knocked out like that yeah so i mean
obviously he did buy a [ __ ]
weird one
that was weird
like an aneurysm or some [ __ ]
he had like a weird flashback or some
[ __ ] and passed out but
just getting pieced up
because of his forward pressure and he
couldn't catch his rhythm yeah and then
second round it got a little better
third i was like he's catching it he's
catching it and he finally caught it and
he's jabbing his face up especially with
guys that are like slow starters like
that because he kind of shane burroughs
is kind of like a like a like a slow
start in that way yeah so it is
interesting to see how that cuz like you
watch the uh
randy costa the guy who looks like harry
potter oh adrian giannis right
on paper like adrian yanez was supposed
to like kind of smash out randy costa a
randy costa put a pace on him and was
just jabbing the [ __ ] out of him and he
wasn't probably expecting that and then
it took him
two rounds for him to be able to like
sleep this [ __ ] mm-hmm guys is
dope man he's so good i actually thought
was gonna lose that [ __ ] fight too
cause his jab was [ __ ] beautiful dude
he was it was perfect randy costas he's
i think he's fighting on the next card
december 11th card but this [ __ ]
he got hands bro he looks hella good and
he looks like harry potter harry potter
that's like dana radford
i'm surprised like janez came out of the
and he just knocked him the [ __ ] he had
a body shot it was the body shot
it was bad
it was so bad yeah so literally had him
up against the cage crack crack right in
the body done fight was over oh you guys
watched canelo fight i saw highlights i
saw the last like four rounds but i
heard the first uh four first like seven
were the same caleb playing like he's
he's pretty good bro like he was a
competitive he he just was able to
neutralize canelo for a good amount of
the fight
and how so just his the outside because
canelo's really good in that like 50 50
position when you're standing in front
of him like that's his [ __ ] right
but caleb was just
outside the ring fighting on the outside
maintain distance he was minimizing the
damage that canelo could do but
eventually he got caught it is what it
is canelo's the [ __ ] greatest boxer
on earth right now like no one's gonna
stop that guy he's he's goat status
right now yeah you know but the fact
that he was able to i'll say this you
survive in the ring with canelo for 11
rounds
pretty g you're pretty good yes yeah
you're pretty high level like you're
your nose [ __ ] slouch what did you
say well canelo is the the first what he
has like all the belts of middleweight
yeah like he you're like before we
continue my friends this podcast is
brought to you
by
stance my friends now if stan sounds
familiar to you they would be the people
that changed the game when it came to
comfort and socks my friends and
underwears i wear
underwear from stance and let me tell
you something the difference between
stance and everybody else it's freaking
soft it feels amazing and if you think
i'm playing look at this if you're
watching this on video i got my stance
songs on right
now probably the most comfortable pair
of socks i've ever worn in my life and
i'm not playing people be walking around
when i take off my shoes because it's
asian style in this house they're like
when you get them stocks i'm like
damn socks you already know it's from
stance my friends a lot of different
designs super dope collabs like for
example harry potter batman the goonies
star wars the office wu-tang clan
freaking disney whatever you can
name
it and i'm telling you right now if you
hate those pieces of crap cloth around
your feet right now that's because you
don't own anything from stance and if
your ball sack is just flip a flopping
around in that rough fabric that's
because you don't have boxes from stance
like i do my friends so check it out the
stance philosophy
is that a perfect fit is more important
than simply fitting in
that those who feel good do good go see
for yourself just head over to
stance.com and pick out whatever styles
you like enjoy the color and comfort of
a life less ordinary with stance that's
crazy wbo wbc whatever the [ __ ] he
follows
ibm gangster [ __ ] that's
when [ __ ] canelo's talks though that
should always get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah get out of here
the funniest thing
it is the line the caleb planting was
that kayla plant called him a
[ __ ] and he was like i beat his
ass because he talked about my mom yeah
and i'm like clearly [ __ ] he's
not talking directly about your mom it's
it's a phrase it's a saying here so
funny and he was acting like he didn't
know even though previous to that he was
in a press conference calling somebody a
[ __ ] yeah i was like shut the
[ __ ] up canelo you know exactly what
that was yeah yeah you don't talk about
my mother but that's the michael jordan
[ __ ] right yeah it's like i gotta i
gotta make you into this [ __ ] monster
for me to be like i'ma [ __ ] this guy
about my mom i know he just heard mother
he was like what'd you say
he started buttoning up his shirt to his
throat
more but the rest of them
yeah dude i think uh canelo is a beast
bro
i don't even know who's gonna fight i
heard maybe triple g again but i mean
triple g is like
yeah but honestly i do think triple g
won definitely the first fight between
them two
possibly the second one too i thought he
won the first and the second yeah so i
mean
the first
because triple g is a [ __ ] gangster
but like
yeah and the first one was some [ __ ]
was not a draw yeah that was [ __ ]
whatsoever dude they were like that's
what we have to do we just have to make
it a draw otherwise this [ __ ]
this is business straight business
do you think did you guys get to hear
what usman and covington were saying to
each other no i just heard like uh
some somebody posted this tick tock of
them like he's like ringside and he i
guess he's the guy that posed for
sportscenter he's the indian guy
whatever the [ __ ] but he was just saying
rum d yeah
and from his what he was saying from
what he heard was he was just
apologizing for the hype and he was like
i gotta i gotta make this fight sorry
bro i but you could i saw a clip i think
it's on youtube where you can kind of
hear it he's just like
he says something along the lines of i'm
trying to inside i'm getting us paid you
know yeah and then was like yeah i get
it and usually does like he said in the
press conference he's like yeah he can
do all this [ __ ] i get it yeah yeah it
helps me i don't got to do all this work
he's the one doing it yeah good for him
like you know and honestly if colby
covington wasn't doing this whole shtick
he wouldn't have sold like this he and
also he
we don't know if he would have fought
for the title multiple times i just
wonder if colby would have knocked him
like beat usman if he would have been
saying the same [ __ ] though you know
like if colby coming to want to knock do
someone out would he have still been
like amen that was awful he would have
been like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
part of me feels like you would you
think so yeah
but i don't know i don't know yeah i
want to see that i want to believe it i
want it like i want to believe the good
of these [ __ ] you know because
i want to believe it's to say like dog
colby's a good guy he did say after did
you watch the press conference
conference after he said he was all uh
twisted american steel and sex appeal oh
my god yeah yeah bro come on dog
that's a good line twisted american
steel
sex appeal my god the only reason why i
know colby covington isn't good at
talking [ __ ] is because he has these
moments where he has to pro
i don't know the press conference right
yeah
he was calling a john morgan he's like
shut up sit s shut up you fl
flabby butt yeah
i think you wanted to call it that yeah
but then he felt bad and was like
shut your little flabby butt sit down
man
written lines for these people oh gosh
so it's like it's not it's not in him
because he's not like chelsea yeah
chelsea you could throw anybody at him
he'll roast the [ __ ] out he was so funny
when he was gone
he has a [ __ ] vendetta again john
africa dude john
john africa let's find john africa on
saturday max hollywood and john africa
and lincoln jingling that's what he
called [ __ ]
leonardo he's in john africa mike tyson
was like he's like
who's john africa
we've talked about this multiple times
it's so [ __ ] funny you call somebody
john africa it's basically he's a black
american it's like that's the most
racist [ __ ] it's like doesn't sound like
his name at all yeah at all dude john
hambrick you know david korea you know
david korea
that doesn't even make sense bro what
the [ __ ] was that dude
about africa helwani is roasting his ass
that's why bro he
he was going after him i felt bad
it was because of i mentioned a little
bit talking about [ __ ] he was it was
because of his like uh conduct as a
co-worker right yeah and he was saying
oh i heard like he's not easy to work
with and that's the thing that set
aerial helwani off
especially if you're arahawani right and
you have all these jobs and you have all
these connections and like to me it
seems like he really does take seriously
what he does like there's no [ __ ]
he's a real like journalist and there's
not that many [ __ ] journalists out
there anymore especially in the mma
space so for him to like take that
personally as far as like saying oh yeah
you're kind of a pain in the ass to work
with i get why he popped off though i'd
be mad too somebody was talking [ __ ]
about like
my job and my business like that and i
know it's not true i'd be pretty [ __ ]
mad especially if it's it's
quote-unquote lies you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he was gonna do he has he
was ripping so i finally caught up on
all of them all the videos of him just
ripping into brenda's shop dude he was
going balls to the wall dude he's like
20 minute monologues let me uh let me go
ahead and call him right now okay he
would call him on the show yeah he
wouldn't pick up and he was like well i
guess you need a little [ __ ] liquid
courage just to go ahead and try to talk
[ __ ] to me yeah i guess um brandon cal
bro brandon callum
brendan cal brandon
brandon america yeah in america
uh brian callan and and uh brenda's shop
were having a drink on their show and
then they were just i guess they were
like [ __ ] around a little tipsy or
whatever
but they were talking a little [ __ ] i
think in fun and just i didn't really
find it that offensive but of course
when they're feuding right or anything
yeah anything can be used it's like fuel
so aaron was like oh i guess you need a
little liquid courage with you and your
buddy to go and talk [ __ ] about me huh
yeah and he just starts going off and he
goes i know stuff about you bro like
brian kelly you don't want to [ __ ] with
this and i'm like no wonder they're not
saying much yeah i feel like for brendan
them i think they they were like looking
at at a scale from one to ten of ten
being the most extreme they were like
it's like a two or three and then era
hawaiian was taken into like a 15 bro
like
he was like really upset by it yeah
right that's what it is what are you
gonna do have you seen uh there was like
a clip i saw of like michael rap report
he was on uh the fighter and the kid a
little obnoxious that focus on my nerves
michael rapaport's nobody really likes
that guy well i i did at first but then
like i heard some [ __ ] where he like
was trying to sue somebody for for
talking [ __ ] about him it was kd and
then yeah and then and then it was like
wait but that's all you do see that's
i think like on the podcast that's true
i'm sorry go ahead because whenever i
like when brian callen's on because i
think brian counts all the funny and so
i'm not saying anything expanded because
better shot but brian brian counts
hilarious and so michael rappaport was
on there and you know you kind of he
kind of sounds like the old guy that
just talks a lot of [ __ ] where he says
like i'll [ __ ] somebody i was like
michael rapport you're not [ __ ]
anybody up bro yeah let's just be real
like i don't really know him like that i
know he's like a pretty big guy but you
talk a lot he talks a lot what are you
saying on the fire of the kid where you
were like well i i think cause i think
it would have gone to the topic of him i
think they're all drinking too they're a
little drunk but um he was like i don't
understand why everybody's [ __ ]
[ __ ] on like brendan shaw blah blah
blah he's like the hardest worker
whatever what not he's like defending
brendan yeah and he's like yeah i wish
one of these [ __ ] would come up
to me i'll [ __ ] beat their ass i'm
like you
it's very interesting you know what i
mean i don't think he was saying in jest
yeah he was saying like for real but i'm
like i don't know does he even train
does he does he fight
i don't think so he was a cop on an
episode of looby one time looby louis uh
he was also a cop in the episode of
friends your favorite show yeah he was
phoebe buffet's boyfriend he was a cop
and he shot a bird a very funny episode
you like friends phoebe hey friends i
need to watch i love you as an adult
as a kid i was watching i'm like this
[ __ ] is whack and i would turn you like
that
i bet you when the they're dancing in
the in the [ __ ] in the pond or
whatever this is david's face like this
hey
he's like yeah
you know how i know both of you are
[ __ ] gay right because [ __ ] it
but because [ __ ] jennifer hansen was
like the hottest white girl ever and you
guys didn't watch that she was hot yeah
but so was uh courtney cox they were hot
but like damn you had to like put
through with all that [ __ ] they were
doing this my show was csi in new york
right damn you know
did you watch it i like the one with the
white dude with the red hair in miami
you always put the glasses on
you guys were watching this we gotta
suck each other's dicks
would you like it
whatever ice tray comes out yeah dude
there was a really funny episode of like
uh of i think gilbert sent it was like
lawn or svu and the guy was like nah i'm
not gay i just have sex with men
and ice cream is like that's gay
he goes yeah that's gay
that's detective work right there baby i
don't even know svu
victims
they used to shoot that episode a lot
for some reason at the apartment that i
used to live in like that show really
yes where did you live i used to listen
close it this place in a cape town
called the talmadge and they would
always shoot like law and order [ __ ]
there and when these commercials
whatever i guess it was like a very
famous spot and each rooms all look
different so they look like new york
apartments and
i don't know what the [ __ ] is it about
but they would shoot every [ __ ] week
there you see that i saw iced tea and
that's when i realized i was like wait
why is he playing a [ __ ] cop
he's a [ __ ] rapper yeah i didn't know
that because i don't watch law and order
[ __ ] because i'm cool like that and so
he was he plays a [ __ ] cop and i
watched an episode of him being a cop
it's the funniest thing i've ever seen
in my life he's real toxic well it's
like
it's like he doesn't mean to everybody
trying to imitate what a cop is right oh
[ __ ] from his land the interesting take
yeah so he's like intake he looks like a
narc
yeah he does you said that hey so i i
was watching this scene of him
interrogating somebody and it's the
funniest [ __ ] show's not good it's
not good it's not good no still every
episode five o'clock last night yeah is
that what you do out there touching
women
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy's
leading questions
yeah so you like to be a scumbag huh and
i'm like why is he talking and the whole
time david's like that's not the perp
that's not him there's no way it's
[ __ ] him it was it was the guy
interview at the beginning every single
time every time every [ __ ] time and
that's the same stroke on that show it's
they catch the guy super early clearly
it's not them because the episode the
[ __ ] end yeah it's just same thing
because i know it's him i saw his semen
everywhere [ __ ]
right and then all of a sudden they
would smell the semen and something like
this smells like my roommates come
that's right so it can't be you
[ __ ]
the fact that they had so many different
versions of it
they have criminal investigations yeah
csi new york my personal favorite they
had csi [ __ ] miami miami and the law
and order svu it's all done with the
same umbrella and they just had law and
order yeah did they so it's like how
people love crime [ __ ] dude the
compilation of the my the miami one i
don't know if you've ever seen the
floodliners the one-liners dude
like he'll like say some cheesy [ __ ]
like uh
like somebody died in a fire or
something and be like
guess they were making s'mores and
they'll put
[Applause]
he finds like a dead body in a lake i
guess they had to put him on ice yeah
exactly
exactly
the theme song kicks in hard as [ __ ]
it's the best this motherfucker's name
was uh david caruso
why were you watching that [ __ ] at 13
that was interesting to you because it
was like it was like the only show that
was on like late at night
like midnight 1 a.m oh really i still
watching when i watched the cindy
margolis show what was that that was
just this hot model that would just be
half naked just doing half naked [ __ ]
what would that be on
the television but it was late at night
public access i don't know pbs
gigantic boobies i think she was like a
maxim model but honestly they used to
have this late night show that would
come on and cindy margolis and like a
bunch of [ __ ] frat people would be on
a beach and then they would do like
bikini swim trunks uh swap uh challenges
oh she's like a play boy bunny huh bro
she's she was fine as [ __ ] oh i've seen
this
yeah i'm pretty sure you dragged me
that was cindy martin's bro
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends ah the awesome better
help that focus on your mental health my
friends as i've always said or asked is
there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals my friends
you know you all been there i am you you
are me
but guess what you are not alone my
friends better help my friends is not a
crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional therapy done securely on
line and betterhelp is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
therapists if needed listen if you have
not tried therapy and you're afraid to
do it in person try online therapy man
it's super affordable specifically
better help is super affordable and on
top of that they offer financial aid for
you guys who might be struggling a
little bit and so don't feel like you
are out there by yourself my friends do
not skip
focusing on your mental health it's
something that i've worked on for the
past few years and better help has been
by my side and i freaking
love it so check it out my friend
special offer for genius brain listeners
you get 10 off your first
oh [ __ ] first month at betterhelp.com
genius check out that cough but once
again special offer for genius brain
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash genius
maybe but i just remember from that late
night show what the [ __ ] would she do on
her show so like a guy and a girl would
swap their bathing suits and say you
would see it in a silhouette and you see
the girl like come out and she's like
covering her booth but she's in the
guy's trunks and the dude would be in
the girls bikini and then i would come
furiously
jennifer anderson had the nipples out
dude on every episode
you guys need to watch friends the fact
that you don't like friends bothers me
yeah i used to watch the slide a lot i
didn't get the jokes but i loved it i
used to watch seinfeld too as a kid i
didn't get the jokes
that's because you're a poser you [ __ ]
you're just laughing for no [ __ ]
reason
i was like that's hilarious jerry that's
hilarious no i didn't i wouldn't even
laugh i would just like watch it and be
like oh cool i would just learn stuff
from tv oh what did you learn from
seinfeld nothing you know the the soup
nazi
just common courtesy
like the things they would complain
about like it's like the larry it's like
curb it's like the [ __ ] you would
complain about you're like oh yeah
that's not okay to do yeah and then that
became part of my uh
like how i saw the world was through the
lens of a jewish man look at this man
just completely make up a story on the
spot right now
the fact that not for rule though
i'm interrogating you right now you know
what breaking down you know what else so
why did you watch seinfeld [ __ ]
huh you just wake up every day and
masturbate so loud in your bathroom that
your dad would hear you and he would
yell at you stop masturbating and that's
why that's a true story bro you're the
great come killer
give me a valley [ __ ]
but not only from seinfeld i would watch
like rom-coms and i would think like
that's what it's like to be in a
relationship and i learned very quickly
what's the first lesson that you learned
from a wrong you know what it is it's
just i thought when you're with a girl
you're supposed to be very lovey dovey
you're supposed to be very like i love
you like very like affectionate and
guess what girls don't really like that
when you're in high school especially
when you're not when you're not with
them yeah exactly
yeah
bro you boy
a real quick yeah that like this is and
i thought that was just my expectation
like that's what i just thought the
world was but once again wrong were you
nervous when you gave your when you had
your first kiss
yeah i was nervous were you practicing a
pillow like a little dweeb
what are you doing nice to meet bryce
there's like a hole inside your [ __ ]
pillowcase and [ __ ]
down my my [ __ ] pillow pillow dude i
said tongue it down really yeah
was tiff your first kiss no
i'm
it was just some girl that i like really
like really liked that
you should just grab your big old ears
like she initiated everything i i was
too much of a player i don't know how to
deal with anything eyes open or are they
close uh
that's a good question should you
[ __ ] grab your balls and be like come
here china boys
you know what i think my eyes were i
don't know bro that's a weird question
to ask what about your first kiss you
[ __ ] weirdo was your eyes open or
closed
i don't remember the guy's beard was
very special
that's very distracting
we should talk about [ __ ] travis
scott and astro world pandemonium yeah
you know what that sounds like sounds
like a good [ __ ] publicity stunt to
go to a travis scott concert like these
[ __ ] dying that's a great
advertisement for how good his concerts
are have you seen the documentary on
this [ __ ] this man is disrespecting the
dead have you i know uh r.i.p but have
you seen this documentary
whatever
[Applause]
wait what so what happened there's a
documentary there's a doc it was before
all this [ __ ] but like it would show how
crazy this fool's concerts would get
what is it about travis scott that
people look so incites it bro what do
you mean i'm not gonna lie how does he
inside it what does he do he just lies
he's doing it he's yelling into the
crowd like oh i thought it was sounds
like normal [ __ ]
yeah but he kind of takes it to another
level he's like kill [ __ ] is he
younger stab everybody that would stick
people with needles yeah yeah there was
a clip of somebody trying to like jack
his shoe
and then he was like get this
[ __ ] yeah beat him the [ __ ] up
like get him [ __ ] this [ __ ] this full up
he was screaming at the crowd to beat up
the person who tried to jack his shoe
yeah which i'm like that's very
different from what you said in your
apology which was like i am so taken
aback by this event i hate it when
people when celebrities do apologies
like that because it sounds so
disingenuous you know that one i i heard
about it i only watched a little clip of
it but it did seem like he was like i
don't know i don't know the thing is
look all right here's the thing i don't
know the full story i know people died
and whatnot cause they were getting
crazy but like
i i see people wanting to blame him but
it's like for way if you're performing
how the [ __ ] do you know what's going on
i think it's because everybody was
coming up to him saying that people were
dying and a lot of people are coming up
on the stage saying there's somebody
dead there's somebody dead yeah telling
him directly like but there's also clips
of him of of him saying like hey you
know help these people out that guy's
passed out and he was like there was i
think one or two of them or something
like that was it the past
uh clip because sometimes the sets kind
of look the same after a while and i'm
curious to see like date wise like was
this a recent one was this from the past
weekend because this happened past
weekend right yeah so i don't even know
if those are all like the right clips
yeah we saw a few clips of people
uploading him trying to help people and
there's another one
this isn't funny but it's kind of funny
they're like somebody was roasting
travis scott or basically trying to
cancel him saying like this people are
dying out here and travis scott is doing
the robot
that's the video that's making its
rounds
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever it's a
pretty good robot though yeah somebody's
dying this motherfucker's like ah
my dog what the [ __ ] is going on it's a
good robot so there was an account of a
of a young lady who was talking about
what happened at the concert right so
she was trying to describe how [ __ ]
nuts it was when people were bum rushing
towards the stage okay said it was so
tight
that it literally felt like people were
like squeezing you
and it got to a point where that girl
recounted where she fell over and when
she fell over she saw somebody's face
like she fell face down and she saw
somebody's face right next to her and
she realized that people were standing
on top of people trampling them the
craziest part about that that she said
was that when she noticed that person's
face there was somebody else beneath
that person oh my god so it was already
two layers of people that were getting
trapped oh my god yeah people were
getting their heads closed game of
thrones exactly so that's like eight
people basically suffocated to death wow
and i saw i heard because a lot of
people were on the news talking about it
like from people's accounts from being
in the concert and they were saying that
there were points in times where it
would get so crushed where people
were literally off the ground like their
feet were off the ground and they're
just being held up by just being
squeezed together yes
so and then uh there was a story of a
couple the girl fell down and the guy
just jumped over her and like just
shielded her from getting trampled
because [ __ ] were rushing
apparently it was like overcrowded
um like i saw a five-year-old
on someone's shoulders at the travis
scott concert and i think who the [ __ ]
would bring a five-year-old to a [ __ ]
travis scott concert too you can see the
documentary it's right right right right
all right all right the production value
is very high uh nah but like it does
seem like he does kind of invite some of
it i know it's like every other artist
but a little more so than normal but is
he is he invite like is he just getting
people amped because there's a big leap
to go from like getting people amped to
being like you know there's a lot of fun
watch the stage like he said [ __ ] like
that like he kind of he kind of incites
it a little bit but then again it's not
his fault that people are going well
kind of i don't know so there's a little
weird thing too where people are saying
like he you know because there's a lot
of like demonic symbolism in this [ __ ]
oh there's people are like the theory
right now is that it was actually a
blood sacrifice that he was like
sacrificing people to like oh okay
well because like his stage is like very
demonic he's like album car cover these
like emo rappers now are doing like the
emo demon [ __ ] right now like little
nazix yeah what was up with that him lap
dancing uh the devil or she was a share
bro i didn't see it i heard it and i was
like what the [ __ ] is that i don't know
i was like bro if you took someone from
the 50s when they thought like rock and
roll was the devil's music and then you
showed them this [ __ ] that's the devil
that's that's literally
what i like their head would explode
yeah i think for a little nazix i think
he's trying to [ __ ] with like
a certain demographic of people that
don't really like him anyway so he's
like i'm gonna [ __ ] with these fools
that's what i think like why should we
go wild though like like religious white
americans who think
him being gay is like the worst thing
ever so he's like man i'm gonna stick it
i'm just gonna make you guys because i'm
not i'm not religious but
i was like [ __ ] damn dude like all
right swinging for the fences how are
you getting soft dog
no i thought it was i just laughed but i
was like yeah this shit's a while like
it's wild
i told you long ago did you see that
music video i don't know is that the one
dancing the [ __ ] devil is that the
one it was that the one i don't know so
this is the one where he's in there's a
bunch of all his backup dancers are are
like gay backup dancers and their butt
naked swinging dick around
in a prison that's it i somehow link
hey what's up music video is wild bro
like if you're homophobic that's gonna
send you straight to heaven yeah right
oh [ __ ] dead heart attack straight to
god i saw a bunch of dick god there's a
there's a dude we know who's like kind
of homophobic and [ __ ]
not kinda he's very homophobic but
he was like yeah low-key and we make fun
of him about all the time like you gay
bro shut up but he's like man little nas
x is [ __ ] trash ball i [ __ ] don't
like this dude he's gay bro like he
people wow
he cites like the music videos he's like
yo this [ __ ] like
like
lap dancing with the devil and and he
he's like pregnant in his pictures and
[ __ ] i'm like you know what's wrong with
that i was like you know you're not
pregnant you know but he
ever since he started talking about how
he doesn't like lil nye's ex we play a
little nausea wherever he is hey he's
out
of fire bro
i like it i'm a fan
old town road i'm a fan of town road
that song you were saying earlier i
don't know the name of it i think like
kanye west was like he produced some of
that too oh he did banger banger dude
yeah that's probably why hey if will you
go to a travis scott concert no no i
don't i don't like concerts like that
dude i don't like that [ __ ] because it
gives me anxiety i don't really know his
music to be honest well i guess because
you're pretty cool like travis i feel
like people who listen to travis scott
are really young i like it like those
concerts i've ever heard a bunch of
young kids right there okay it's like 18
year olds or [ __ ] and they like mosh and
[ __ ] is it like is it like crazy like
amped that [ __ ] i just don't like people
that close to me though yeah i want that
[ __ ] oh yeah that's terrible [ __ ] i'm
not into mosh pits i don't like the
thought
of a mosh pit like we went to uh kanye
west we saw the saint pablo tour and we
had the general mission we're on the
ground floor
i honestly that was probably one of the
coolest [ __ ] concerts i've ever been to
like this dude his production quality
amazing but
you do get really nervous when all these
[ __ ] are like trying to leave
the arena
and everyone's pushed up against you and
like i was getting pissed bro i was like
yo back the [ __ ] up like i don't like
i'm very claustrophobic whenever i go to
concerts i get very anxious because i
don't like when there's a lot of people
because it is yeah very weird there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] that happens and sure
enough when you i watch the videos of
the travis scott concert look what
happens bro that [ __ ] scares the [ __ ]
out of me because it's like there's
nothing you could do you're just yeah
you're just you're [ __ ] did you
imagine they got people got trampled on
like it was walmart did you hear about
the black friday yeah
there was people like injecting
[ __ ] too i heard was it
fentanyl is that why i don't know what i
just heard somebody was just injecting
people with random like what the [ __ ]
probably maybe yeah probably i don't
doubt it like drugs are crazy nowadays
man everybody be doing like fit now
do you think people are wild and extra
because of kovit
i don't know if it's because of kobet
per se but i think it's just the general
like party life and culture is
the hot thing to do now yeah cause back
in the day was gangbang like like like
you gotta play it cool all the time yeah
you can't show that you like [ __ ] you
can't show that you [ __ ] with [ __ ] too
heavy yeah or people call you a [ __ ]
loser yeah even if you like stuff like
if you really like i don't know let's
say you like pumpkin pie right yeah and
they go you like pumpkin pie i'm like
actually i
you know you always had to play things
cool but now it's about hey let's get
[ __ ] up let's drink let's party let's
get smashed because who the [ __ ] cares
nothing matters right yeah that's like
the hot [ __ ] that all the music reflects
that all the the emo rap this is what's
cool now so i feel like the crazier you
are the more attention you get the more
views you get the more tick-tock
followers you get that's true so it's
different now right so if you take that
incentive away let's say all the social
media should disappear the only thing
that alive was youtube yeah you couldn't
post what you're doing every day you
think half these people be doing that
absolutely not that becomes for the
cloud that's so crazy to think about
because that's very true like you look
at all the guys that are very popular on
like tick-tocking on this [ __ ] it's just
partying doing wild [ __ ] like crazy
[ __ ] that nobody would ever do i'll tell
you this like i have a buddy of mine
who's been going to burning man for like
probably 20 years now do you think
people die in burning man like that oh
for sure from multiple different types
of aids that you don't even know
right stds straight up the yin yang yeah
that's your bumps on your dick lip and
your ears people be [ __ ] that burning
man huh yeah hardcore my buddy james
used to go to he's he's been going to
burning man consistently for 20 years
and even then he sees the change like
the people who would come to burning man
so like people who went to birdie men
were people who were like who want to be
off the grid do a [ __ ] ton of shrooms
and drugs there was no cameras there
like in terms of like sharing for social
media yeah it would just be for like
your own memories experience like you
know i thought it was always for like
white hippies like really like hippy
dippy
kind of like off the spectrum weirdos
kind of like it was a big judgy so one
of my girlfriends she used to love going
to burning man and [ __ ] but at the time
i was like hyper christian so i was like
i can't do that demon [ __ ] dude
yeah i was a [ __ ] youth minister you
guys should be going to burning man you
know what i mean now i see people who
should have gone bernie man are all like
dressed up they do like these weird like
it's kind of a play on burning man yeah
kinda yeah and they dress up and they're
people that i never thought would ever
go to burning man i would typically see
these people at like edc or yeah other
like coachella and now the same people
are going to bernie the burning man edc
crowd is like starting from what he told
me is kind of like meshing now right
it's like this young hip cool thing to
do right before it was like very
exclusive like if you [ __ ] with
burning man you wanted to drive to the
middle of a [ __ ] desert and start
doing hella drugs and just start [ __ ]
and sucking dick or just like enjoying
music out there having a spiritual
experience so they have performances out
there um
i think so but from what he i'm okay
from what he told me he was just saying
it was like a spiritual experience for
him yeah he's been doing that for super
super years a lot of people they have
like art all over the place that they
create in the making they set it on fire
i guess and they do the burning man [ __ ]
they burn the dude it became super
commercialized and so even like the
burning man aspect of what it was is
starting to change like i don't know i
personally haven't been there but this
is from a guy who's been going there for
20 years you know yeah yeah so when once
once people start doing stuff for the
for the idea of i want people to
recognize me it's different now yeah
crazier and crazier things yeah you're
right so you're right and for sure like
you said social media just exponentially
made it crazier as [ __ ] you know yeah
would you go to burning man i would go
i'll [ __ ] wait i would go for sure
just to see you like what's what's up
you wouldn't want to see that crazy
weird [ __ ]
i'm bored dude i'm so [ __ ] boring dog
like i don't really like to do all that
[ __ ] i'll do it for a couple hours and
be like all right i'm good
yeah but why are you laughing you know
this about me like old ass man i kind of
came old man bro we got prune juice
there
they don't got prune
oh my word come on dog i got dandruff
enough in the winter time if i go to
burning man your boy's gonna be making
it snow over there yo [ __ ] that you
gotta go see what it's about though all
those weirdos the weird art they do like
we all kinds of weird [ __ ] it's just
like a dis crazy experience
it's just something that you've never
experienced ever before some wild ass
[ __ ] where you're gonna see people are
interacting away people be coming back
with mono though don't kiss anybody
don't [ __ ] anybody
don't do drugs just go like as an
observer just be like what do people get
into there's no money like so people
exchange like like barter system there's
no cash so you can get drinks and
everything but you have to like i'll
trade like a [ __ ] bracelet for a beer
or something like that i don't know what
i'm trying to bracelets for this
i gotta exchange [ __ ] my money for
bracelets to use as currency you just
take [ __ ] that you don't want at the
house and you take it out that you
[ __ ]
give somebody a pen that doesn't work
stapler that doesn't work and get a
[ __ ] blow job
that's a bad deal
what do you mean [ __ ] people over
here that is amazing
there's a pen that doesn't work now suck
my dick like that's like i don't feel i
don't feel comfortable about that i feel
like i'm taking advantage no because
it's a mutual decision that's true yeah
that's pretty cool man yeah i'm in let's
go to bernie and then do you know what
i'm suck as if afterwards mouth will
come she tries to write and it doesn't
work she's like what the [ __ ]
um i don't like people that's a no bro
give him some [ __ ] how can you not give
you've not given him [ __ ] i feel like if
i go to brian
it's gonna be slap city all over again
copy and paste
yeah somebody's gonna you're not
interested in seeing like that we're
like just because it's you know is there
a live stream i'll watch that i mean
like i'm pretty sure it'd be kind of an
interesting story to have me going to
burning man but i'll probably last there
a day at most because i don't really do
drugs like that i don't think i don't
even like disneyland dude think about
like the the amount of people that it's
at disneyland
and then you multiply that with whatever
burning man is and then just how close
everybody is in proximity and
like the energy is very different the
pretense of what you're at burning man
for is gonna be very different you're
gonna have so many random people coming
up to you just like [ __ ] with you
i know i'm supposed to enjoy it yeah
dude it's like hey come here [ __ ] with
me i'm like get the [ __ ] away from me
dude yeah david's very particular i
think yeah exactly blessings blessings
and they'd probably be like all right
man all right that's your journey that's
your energy man that's your energy man
respect it yeah i could barter you this
fist to your [ __ ] face if you don't
walk away how about that yeah yeah
blessings and blessings like i don't
think i would even go to coachella
i would rather go to burning man than
coach because
more like a concert like burning man
seems like some one one unique type [ __ ]
to see we do okay this is what we're
doing the next burning man
and we're doing ayahuasca we should
interview people at burning man that'd
be cool dude that would be great so how
many aids do you have like three thank
you and then three yeah a new strain
that nobody has ever seen before i'm
dying right now
dude honestly we should go and like just
have a little like can you you can't
record out there can you we just put
like little pretty sure you could record
[ __ ] out there well i don't know i don't
know if there's like a little i mean i'd
be watching some burning man porn every
now and then yeah really what's that
like
like years ago i
i saw like somebody posting up clips you
like when you just surf through porn
yeah it was like it was at a concert
where a girl was sucking somebody's dick
and that's burning man oh great i was
like i don't think they i'm not sure if
they just do that out there but it was
very interesting and it didn't look like
it was like set up porn it looked like
it was just something that was happening
it was just happening spontaneous i'm
like why the [ __ ] is this person just
have like this indian native american
hat sucking dick in the middle of a
desert and it was a it was like a
burning man or something
that's what happened
well you know what that's going to cost
yeah a [ __ ]
that's a great deal that's what you do
if you're ever going to have a yard sale
don't do that just take all your [ __ ] to
burning man get all [ __ ] and then
just balance and you had a good time
we all know why he wants to go yeah
dude
for not wanting to go to burning man
just to see it for a day like we could
just go for one day just to like drive i
don't know
it's like it's in the desert so
three hours yeah it's just three hours
away all right we go for a day if we
leave about five if you're like if you
guys i'll [ __ ] go to burning man
i would actually like to go with you
guys the most because i think it'd be
funny as [ __ ]
yeah we're going to squirm
dude
but we got to go in and if he has
ayahuasca then we have to take it even
though i'm scared and i don't know would
you guys take ayahuasca i'm scared i've
thought about taking ayahuasca but i'm
also really scared i'm [ __ ] scared
because i've i know two people who had
very very bad experiences with it and
that's like i've only talked to maybe a
handful of people who've done it and two
out of a handful is way too much yeah
you know like i'm talking about i know
somebody who like flipped out divorce
tells the story you know oh yeah the
whole [ __ ] so coffee shop guy right yep
hate that can't do it i can't do it like
i don't want to wake up one day just
look at merrell we are not meant to be
yeah yeah but that guy he kind of made a
big choice though didn't he
like
he
did ayahuasca and then immediately was
like [ __ ] everything i did in the past
this is a new life i had another buddy
crazy and that's great you did like
ayahuasca and he came outside so how do
you feels like it was trippy did you
learn anything he goes
nope
that [ __ ] was just really trippy
yeah that could work that that's that's
pretty cool because it's better than the
other one so a lot of people are doing
it for what that spiritual journey kind
of that that that unlocks something like
inhibitions that you had before or makes
you see things about yourself that you
didn't know about yeah my buddy did uh
ayahuasca recently and he's like the
second time he did it he went on a
retreat
and he was telling me that it was like
it's more of the [ __ ] that he deals with
internally that he doesn't understand
why he feels a certain way about like
say like he has imposter syndrome or
something he's like i don't know why i
feel this way but for him he was saying
his visions were about like his
childhood and like his parents and like
him looking down at him as a kid
dealing with his parents and then
like their relationship and then just
being able to
change it
and that was his vision like it would it
would repeat until he got it right i
guess he got he hammed the situation
right so sounds like therapy yeah kind
of right so it is a little different for
everybody and how you kind of manage it
but you know definitely don't pretty
sure regular therapy probably would have
worked for him
yeah probably and i think so too yeah
couldn't i told him all right so this
was
burning man you're gonna take some
ayahuasca uh just me this year just you
and we're gonna record it yeah we're
gonna watch you
why am i the guinea pig because you have
to do it i'll just throw up everywhere
because you're the one who doesn't even
drink alcohol nothing that's true i
smoke pot nah who says pot grandpa i
know good lord dude the [ __ ] dude what
are you what do you call this it's a pot
stick dude
it's a pot
dude
right now dude and take a hit on my pot
sticks right here with the kids he's
like hey kids you guys have any pot
sticks
you know marijuana joint you guys got
some wacky taffy yeah
invited the cop dude that's what i call
it show me a little while do you think i
look like a cop
yeah
can you especially with my head shaved a
little bit yeah you look like you know
once you start talking and interacting
no but you're the way you look and the
fact that you call it pot yeah
that's what my dad calls it did you see
that clip on twitter of this guy who's
like clearly an undercover cop
this is the funniest [ __ ] video this
dude's like this yolked out buff white
guy with like a buzz cut uh-huh and he's
like i'm looking for some crack bro i'm
looking to get i'm looking for some
crack bro and he's like
this dude's like recording he was like
you a cop [ __ ]
[Applause]
get the [ __ ] out of here bro
[ __ ] cop like you wanna get the
[ __ ] out of here it's like nah man you
got any good stuff you're gonna be good
stuff wow
look at this i gotta watch that's like
the little devil's liquid i don't even i
don't even know how to use the prop when
people say i don't smoke or do anything
i like it and i'm gonna be cool that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
i'm drinking right now what can they
find you you stupid [ __ ]
it's mostly water how the [ __ ] ice
cubes melted we barely put any liquor in
there it's pretty good it was gin you
find me nick the ear pretty good it was
just on instagram and you can find patch
get patrick dot t-dot riley that's me
that me
that's your boy and then he's playing
every thursday venus
penis genius brain every thursday
sundays until next year at january first
it's only once a week baby you better
get your fix now yeah get it in baby but
we're gonna be [ __ ] switching [ __ ] up
let's go it's gonna be really nice see
you all next time peace